i just want to thank you all for your
love and support
over the years
betty white's longtime assistant kirsten
mikolas shares the hollywood icon's
final message to fans
thank you so much
and
stick around
kirsten posted that sweet clip to
instagram friday explaining in the
caption that it was meant to be shared
on january 17th what would have been
betty's 100th birthday
you can't get much better than that
quote she was using the occasion of her
100th birthday to celebrate you her fans
she knew how lucky she was she felt the
love and she never took it for granted
and the luckiest old brought on two feet
that's what she always called herself
the luckiest old bro she never looked at
herself too seriously she brought
laughter and happiness and
a lot of love to a lot of people
of course the golden girl star died on
new year's eve just 17 days shy of her
milestone birthday and kirsten
previously shared this snap of betty
filming that message to fans revealing
in the caption that it was taken on
december 20th adding that at 99 years
old betty was quote radiant and
beautiful and as happy as ever
december 20th she did a
short little video for us it was kind of
a tribute to her fans that are going to
be with with her
at the event we're going to be with her
at the event and it's kind of a shout
out to her fans that she did
10 days before she passed away
following the news of her death producer
steve beaucher teased that he had filmed
with betty that same day as part of her
once in a lifetime movie event betty
white a celebration which premiered on
betty's birthday in 1500 theaters
nationwide first of all she looks
amazing she loved getting glammed up as
she calls it and her hair makeup this is
striking and beautiful a beautiful green
top on bright colored and she was
smiling and really she wanted to thank
her fans sincerely from the bottom of
her heart i just want to thank you all
for your love and support
over the years
according to the death certificate
obtained by et the beloved actress
suffered a stroke six days before her
death
i think all of us truly believe that she
would just live forever jennifer love
hewitt who starred alongside betty in a
2011 hallmark film reflected on the late
star's life and legacy with e.t i feel
so sad that i will never get to
laugh with her again or see her again
but i also feel so
joyful seeing all of the things that
people are putting out about her and how
much they meant to her and how
you know how she kept us laughing and
earlier this week betty's hot in
cleveland co-star valerie bertinelli
said it was her friend's kindness that
she'll miss most
she oozed kindness and it wasn't a
struggle for her it just that's who she
was she was a kind
kind human being
thank you so much
and
stick around
you